Speaker 1: All right. Absolute last thing. On the
wacky weekend in Anchorage, Alaska, the asinine
Anchorage, Alaska weekend. Mypillow CEO
Mike Lindell did show up at the rally.
He claimed that votes were stolen from
Donald Trump in Alaska. Now I know
English is my second language, but votes were
stolen from Donald Trump. Sounds wacky and it also
sounds untrue. Trump won in Alaska, by the way.
Speaker 2: We all know here in Alaska, over 29,000
votes were stolen from Donald Trump. Oh, God.
Speaker 1: I mean, it's the Saturday Night
Live is going to be out of business.
Speaker 2: Y'all know here in Alaska,
over 29,000 votes were stolen from Donald Trump.
Speaker 1: Right?
Speaker 2: So it happened everywhere in our
country. And as you all know, I've said it,
we have to get rid of the machines and
the voting machines. Right. We're doing a
class action lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: Now, remember that in Alaska,
Donald Trump won easily in 2020, 52 to 42. Very,
very easy win. But pillow is convinced votes were
stolen from Donald Trump. And then lastly, I know
at this point it's indistinguishable from satire.
But Mike Pillow has a new date for Donald
Trump being reinstated. And it's next month.
It's about five, six weeks away, either August
20th or 21st. It will be the biggest thing
in our lifetimes and it might be what
gets Donald Trump finally reinstated.
Speaker 2: It's just so exciting because it's just
all going to lead up everybody to and I got to say
this August 20th and 21st, the biggest event in
this country in our lifetime, I believe it's the
most important event ever in the history in our
lifetime. What this is going to do, the will be
in Springfield, Missouri, lives right near the.
Speaker 1: World, the natural place, of course,
for the biggest event of our lifetimes. I
mean, no offense to Springfield, Missouri,
but surprising certainly that that's where
the biggest event is going to take place.
Speaker 2: And it's a two day event. It's
invite only. You guys will be there. Yeah,
you said that it's an invite only. So
it's a spread in Springfield, Missouri.
Yeah. Springfield, Missouri is so important.
There'll be, you know, the invites will be
going out. These will be influencers, podcasters,
grassroots. It will be a bunch of church leaders.
Okay. And when we do this, everybody I imagine
every state will be getting up there saying,
you know, here's our footprint. You're all going
to hear what the good going, where's our home? You
know, the next day will be everything of our what
what do you say they can do individually to get.
Speaker 1: Yep. So very, very clear. It's going
to be an incredible August 20th and 21st. Now,
you guys may or may not remember, but Mike Pillow,
during my interview with him actually said I could
go to his symposium if I wanted. He referred to
it as the symposium, but I think it was a cyber
symposium. He said, If I wanted to go to that, I
could. He gave me his personal cell phone number
maybe. I mean, I know that there's so many church
leaders that are going to be there that they might
not have room for me. But should I contact pillow
and say, sir, I'd love to go to the biggest event
of our lifetimes and check out what's going to
go on and how every state is going to do this.
Or maybe I'll just stay home. I don't know. Let
me know what you think I should do. So that closes
the loop on this wild and wacky weekend asinine
Anchorage, Alaska rally not particularly full.
It was a 5000 seat venue whose upper deck was not
completely sold out. There were actually seats
everywhere. So I know it's Alaska and there's not
that many people there. So maybe that's what's to
blame. Maybe the glisten and shine of Trump is
receding. Actually, Trump was glistening a lot,
but that was he was sweating on Saturday night. We
will look at the data coming up soon. So that does
it on this topic for today. We're going to take
a quick break. We are going to review an absolute
clinic master class by Pete Buda, a judge on Fox
News over the weekend. We're going to talk about
these boring gun talking points being shot down
by senator dick durbin. We have a lot still to
come. Facebook.com, slash, David Pakman show. Make
sure you give us a like and we will be right back.